c'est lors de notre second débat
consacrée au bilan du mouvement mitu
notamment dans le monde politique la
sphère damien abad ne fait plus la une
de l'actualité la justice n'a pas ouvert
d'enquêté en l'état mais cette affaire
continue d'empoisonner la campagne de la
majorité présidentielle
le rappel des faits pour commencer avec
jérôme rabier tout juste nommé le
gouvernement d'elisabeth borgne a tout
de suite été placé sur la défensive
médiapart dévoilé dès le lendemain de
l'annoncé du gouvernement que damien
abad nouveau ministre des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
a fait l'objet de signalements pour des
faits présumés de viol sur deux femmes
l'ancien président du groupe l air à
l'assemblée censé être une prise de
guerre de la macro ni a dû prendre la
parole sur ces faits
réfutant tout acte non consenti je n'ai
jamais violé une seule femme de ma vie
vous comprendrez qu aborder ces sujets
publiquement est extrêmement douloureux
pour moi désormais je me consacre à ma
mission de ministre un ministre qui
souhaite être sur le terrain mais
l'affairé a mis tout le gouvernement
sous pression elisabeth borgne a dû s'en
expliquer sur le terrain tout comme la
nouvelle porte parole du gouvernement à
la sortie du conseil des ministres la
justice
est la seule à devoir et à pouvoir
trancher à ma connaissance
moment où nous nous parlons
aucune autre procédure n'est en cours à
l'endroit de damien abad la justice qui
a classé une des deux affaires en 2017
et qui en l'état n'ouvrira pas de
nouvelles enquêtes faute d'avoir pu
identifier la seconde victime présumée
qui veut rester anonyme
l'observatoire des violences sexistes et
sexuelles en politique qui a recueilli
puis signalé les faits au parti elle est
réelle rer et enfin la justice dénonce
un double discours du gouvernement sur
ce sujet la porte parole du gouvernement
l'est via grégoire a dit qu'elle
encourageait la libération de la parole
et pour autant et décide de conserver un
homme accusé de viol c'est extrêmement
grave damien abad est pour l'instant
maintenu au gouvernement mais de façon
plutôt discrète sans intervention
médiatique il reste également le
candidat de la majorité dans la 5e
circonscription de l'ain en cas de
défaite il serait alors contraint de
démissionner en levant une épine du pied
à l'exécutif mais en cas de victoire son
maintien ou non au gouvernement
relèvera d'un vrai choix politique
le bilan du mouvement me tout en
politique voilà le thème du débat que
vous propose tout de suite avec mélanie
vogel bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice écologiste des françaises et
des français de l'étranger giulia foïs
bonsoir ça d'être journaliste
présentatrice de l'émission pas son
genre sur france inter et auteur de je
suis une sur deux publié aux éditions
flammarion
sabine pro choristes bonsoir philosophe
psychanalyste auteur du mirage mis tous
est publié aux éditions le cherche midi
et lætitia que pas y rester à mes côtés
laetitia alors on va commencer après le
reportage qui rappelait les faits de
cette affaire damien abad par vous
entendre sur ce thème précis mélanie
vogel vous avez signé vous avait relayé
la pétition de l'observatoire des
violences sexuelles et sexistes ans en
politique qui réclament la démission du
ministre pourquoi
bien parce que on peut plus avoir des
personnes accusées du jeune en
responsabilité politique
je quand on voit en fait la non réaction
du gouvernement au plus tôt la réaction
comme si s'était rien passé en fait
parce que je crois que le but de
l'émission c'est de faire un peu de
parler du mouvement mythe où ils
réagissent vraiment comme si on était
encore avant ce mouvement et d'un côté
je les comprends parce que c'est vrai
que pendant très longtemps et bien quand
les femmes parler et qu elle dénoncé des
faits de viol il ne se passait rien et
en fait on voit que ils ont toujours pas
compris qu'il s'était passé quelque
chose avec me tout et qu'en fait on n'en
veut plus on veut plus des violeurs au
gouvernement on veut plus des hommes mis
en cause pour viol et voilà et on va pas
les lâcher et ça va continuer et le fait
de dire je trouve ça hallucinant un de
dire où il n'a pas été jugé c'est vrai
et d'ailleurs
c'est pas ça la question la question
c'est qui les miens oui le parquet de
paris n'a pas ouvert d'enquêté en l'état
je vois là très bien aussi qu'ils
n'avaient pas le vrai prénom de la
plaignante de l'accusatrice très bien et
donc je allé l'interroger ils nous
disent c'est quand même il faut
s'entendre ce que de la confusion que
c'est donc ils nous disent il ya que la
justice qui peut trancher comme si
c'était la justice qui nommer les
ministres je veux dire ça n'a rien à
voir un et ce n'est pas les juges ne
nomme pas les ministres moi j'ai pas été
nommé ministre parce que je suis pas
présumée innocente ok c'est pour des
raisons de politique parce que j'ai rien
à faire politiquement dans ce
gouvernement on a le choix quand on
nomme un gouvernement de choisir plein
de gens est-ce qu'on choisit damien abad
où est-ce qu'on joue avec un côté ce
juge voilà juste dire une chose ce qui
est totalement hallucinant c'est qu'ils
nous disent il n'y a que la justice qui
peut trancher mais en fait c'est des
électeurs et les électrices qui vont
décider quand ils vont voter aux
élections législatives s'il considère
que damien abad au fond est blanchi ou
non face et ce que lui a dit c'est ce
que damien abad
adissan relevé il sent ils s'en
remettaient effectivement au à la
décision des électeurs giulia foïs le
fait que le parquet de paris n'est pas
ouvert d'enquêté dans cette affaire est
ce que ça change votre perception ou pas
de nom pourquoi du tout parce que parce
que faut bien comprendre dans quel
contexte en se plaçant se place dans un
contexte où effectivement les femmes
parlent elles ont toujours parlé on
connaît le nombre de femmes qui sont
victimes de violences conjugales c'est
plus de 200 milles de nombre de femmes
violées chaque année c'est 97000 10% de
plaintes vous voyez c'est le taux de
dollar reste inchangé vous voyez le
nombre de plaintes qu'on a chaque année
en france à l'arrivée vous avez 1 à 2 %
seulement des violeurs qui finissent ou
des viols plutôt qu'ils finissent
condamnés aux assises qu'est ce qui se
passe entre temps il se passe un taux de
classement sans suite qui est
hallucinant qui va bien au delà des taux
de classement sans suite pour d'autres
affaires et de classement sans suite
c'est quoi ça ne veut pas dire
le viol n'a pas eu lieu ça veut dire on
n'a pas suffisamment d'éléments question
les a tant cherché
fait-on preuve réellement de bonne foi
alors moi dans un monde idéal j'ai une
justice qui fonctionne et j'ai des juges
qui sont impartiaux et j'étais juste
qu'ils sont bien formés qui font
correctement leur travail en l'état
actuel des choses je prends une autre
affaire la sphère 200 d'endroits ils
face à luc besson
classement sans suite deux fois ok sauf
que dans la procédure la juge
d'instruction a refusé de rencontrer
sans banderoles refusé de confronter
sans le vendront ya du vaisseau et
refuser de confronter luc besson a des
photos qui avait été prise le soir même
où l'on voit très clairement une
ecchymose à l'oeil et une lésion annales
donc le classement sans suite n'ont en
l'état ça veut pas dire grand chose et
je rejoins dit que je pense que di
milano j'ai longtemps c'est que vous
faites pas vraiment confiance à la
justice maintenant
en l'état non pas un état bien sûr que
non quand on en est assez tôt la de
condamnation c'est pas possible on est à
la rue on à la rue en france là dessus
et comme comme le disait mais dany vos
gènes est ce qu'on est sûr que quand on
se place cinq ans après le début de mitu
est ce qu'on est sûr qu'on n'a pas assez
d'hommes et de femmes compétents dans ce
pays qui n'auraient pas d'accusations de
viol à leur encontre qu'on pourrait
nommer un des portefeuilles ministériels
est ce qu'on pourra avoir conscience de
l'époque sabine pro choristes vous vous
dites que dans cette affaire l'agenda
est grossier c'est ce que vous avez dit
c'est ce sont des accusations qui
remonte un certain temps qui en effet
une des accusatrices avaient comment il
ya eu deux plaintes de la première
accusatrice puisqu'elle avait commencé
par porter plainte mais on s'est désisté
en route bien que la police l'ait
relancé à plusieurs reprises et ensuite
la deuxième plainte en 2017 s'est
classée sans suite après enquête parce
que les faits ne sont pas qualifiés
suffisamment ça c'est les règles de la
justice tout justiciable il est soumis
voilà ça c'est une chose donc oui
l'agenda est grossier parce que c'est
quand même un peu étrange m'enfin c'est
pas ça le principal si vous voulez mais
c'est important c'est quand même un peu
frais enfin assez frappant je pense qu'à
n'échappe à personne que du jour où ce
monsieur est nommé ministre
hop voilà que ça sort et qu'on nous
explique qu'on ne veut pas de violeurs
ou d'accuser de viol au gouvernement la
confusion est en fait puisque la tribune
mitu politique voulait que tout mis en
cause soit écartée d'emblée de la vie
politique c'est la même chose dans huit
ou théâtre c'est la même chose partout
ça veut dire quoi c'est à partir
effectivement d'un décret d'eau au fond
du mouvement mis tous c'est-à-dire
victimes on vous croit autrement dit à
partir du moment où une accusation est
formulée
vos preuves pour moi ça ça ne va pas et
vous disiez tout à l'heure que ce ne
sont pas les juges qui nomme les
ministres mais ce ne sont pas non plus
les politiques n'est ce pas qu'ils ont à
juger des personnes donc oui c'est à la
justice de faire son travail si la jeune
femme en vert dans lequel je termine il
n'existe pas encore dans ce pays de
plein de sous x je suis il existe des
témoignages et de plantes sous x donc je
termine donc oui je pense que c'est dans
la partie moment il n'y a pas de
procédure judiciaire ouvert n'y a pas de
sujet est donc
injuste argumentaire est incomplet dont
je vous ai dit c'est terminé vous avez
quand même oublier qu'en 2010 est déjà
on lui avait reproché les mêmes faits
puisqu'il y avait déjà les accusations
selon vous dites comme par hasard ça
sort là parce qu'on l'a nommé de
ministres mais en 2010 est déjà quand il
était donc avec françois fillon non mais
on est d'accord mais voilà que ça pour
dire que une affaire ne ressort pas ne
sort pas là que mon fils sont maintenant
s'il était connu par tout le personnel
politique
je m'étonne quand même que des enfin
vous êtes senna nominé
jeter alice jeune mais wallon peut
laisser terminer je m'étonne qu'une
sénatrice élue de la république souhaite
en fait que soi que fonctionne dans ce
pays grâce notamment aux fins grâce si
on peut lire grâce coup par
l'intermédiaire notamment des médias des
réseaux sociaux un système
extrajudiciaires moi je suis absolument
opposé à cela alors votre réponse non
mais parce que c'est c'est une confusion
c'est vous qui êtes dans la confusion
non pas du tout moi je ne demande pas
est-ce que damien abad aille en prison
sans être jugé d'accord je ne demande
pas là bas dit soit vous voulez qu'ils
soient dégagées de boudin ou si je
pouvais je les soigne ministre parce que
la politique c'est des symboles des
damiers un bagne en a partout d'accord
des hommes accusés de viol mis en cause
pour viol des viols y en a partout
le fait est que quand on choisit des
ministres ont fait un choix politique on
envoie un signal qu'elles signalent ont
choisi est ce qu'on choisit d'envoyer
comme signal d'amis abad accusé du viol
par plusieurs personnes dont on dit
parce que il ya eu des personnes chez
les républicains depuis qu'ils en
parlaient qui ont dit oui alors j'ai été
approché parce qu'ils avaient des
comportements inappropriés avec les
femmes et c est ce qu ont choisi lui ou
est ce qu'on choisit quelqu'un d'autre
ça c'est un choix politique ça n'a aucun
rapport est la justice je ne mets pas en
cause sa présence son innocence qui
était en cours de partie vous l'aviez
mois puisque le credo de millet ou sa
victime on vous quoi vous mettez en
cause la présence à hand in addition
c'est de savoir à quoi ça sert de
libérer la parole et des risques ça
c'est la parole dès qu'elle est quel est
l'objectif de dire aux femmes parler
quand elle parle il ne se passe rien
c'est intéressant là vous aviez dire aux
femmes parlaient comme il était une
armée qui devait répondre à vos
injonctions non mais c'est pas moi qui
dis aux femmes parler donc moi ce que
vous appelez un an jean castex l'a dit
mais maintenant on a dit aussi il faut
parler il faut que les femmes parlent ça
vient plutôt que ce genre l'injonction
vient plutôt du gouvernement les
finalistes artiste pas comme ça tous les
politiques comme toute la classe
politique mais entièrement je dirais je
comment dire ça à emboîter le pas au
mouvement me touche on prendre un
instant de distance à l'annoncé
dans la cause défendue par me tout est
une très bonne cause ça on n'y a aucun
doute là dessus maintenant la confusion
avec laquelle mitu défend cette cause
est absolument délétère c'est pas pour
rien que j'ai écrit un livre entier là
dessus parce qu'au début sur lie to me
range oui je parle de mirage parce qu'au
début moi j'étais absolument partager
sur ce mouvement parce qu'en effet il ya
des vraies questions qui sont soulevées
comme une féministe présager que vous et
depuis longtemps jeté jeune jeune femme
au moment où le viol a été recréée
analyse est d'ailleurs il faut savoir
que au moment où le viol a été repris mi
na li zhe malheureusement les les
verdicts ont été beaucoup plus clément
parce que les jurés est tellement pris
dans dans les préjugés était beaucoup
moins sévères que les juges quand
c'était en correctionnelle mais ça c'est
une parenthèse donc oui bien sûr que les
questions sont importantes mais les
logiques du mouvement sont tout à fait
folle falsificatrice ne serait-ce que de
mettre dans le même sac violence
sexuelle et sexiste qu'est ce que vous
faites de ce qui se passe par exemple
dans le collectif 50 50 du cinéma
français où c'est une femme qui accuse
une femme ou d'un meeting où c'est un
homme qui accuse anneaux est ce que
c'est sexiste alors j'aimerais bien vous
m'expliquer ça julia phone vous donne la
parole à ces l'impression d'être
interrogé par ma prof mais fait je vais
vous répondre le contexte est pas quand
même reprécisons encore une feinte
replaçons le cas à battre dans un
contexte qui est plus général moi ce que
ce que dit mélanie vogel et j'y souscris
à 300% et toutes les féministes s'il
s'agit pas d'envoyer à badens prison il
s'agit de se dire que le temps que la
justice fasse son travail on puisse
considérer ils soient dans l'intérêt
public et dans l'intérêt de ce
gouvernement de le suspendre de lemaitre
oui aller qu'à regarder françois de rugy
ya même pas de mise en cause judiciaire
on considère que pour une histoire de
homard une faut qu'il démissionne
cahuzac il est mis en cause par accuser
pour une histoire de détournement de
fraude fiscale il démissionne
au modem c'est pareil quand il a fait
les enfers usa qu'un il a pas d'émission
me l'a fait mais sans être condamné oui
mais sans être condamné donc on n'a pas
attendu qu'ils soient condamnés on l'a
fait bayrou de sarnez ils ont dégagé bon
sûr on est à l'ouverture d'une enquête
on y est on y reviendra plus tard sur
sur la façon dont on vient on y
reviendra sur la façon dont le
gouvernement macron effectivement défend
ou pas ses ministres mais je tiens je
vais vous de redonner la parole sur sur
une autre argument et je voudrais bien
vous entends la tuque et l'argument cac
à porter sandrine rousseau l'ancienne
candidate aux primaires d'europe
écologie les verts pour justifier
effectivement de mettre à l'écart ou
d'appeler à là démission de damien abad
elle parle de principe de précaution
écoutez la la question n'est pas sa
démission à lui mais le fait qu'il soit
démis de ses fonctions par principe de
précaution il ya deux il y a deux
témoignages de femmes qui ne se
connaissent pas qui sont concordants qui
relate des faits qui sont assez
similaires et par ailleurs manifestement
chez les républicains il ya une année il
était précédé d'une réputation que
plusieurs personnes ont confirmé
plusieurs cadres des républicains ont
confirmé donc il ya un principe de
précaution qui fait qu'il faut protéger
et il faut envoyer un message assez fort
aux femmes que leurs paroles compte
ça sous-entend que damien abad est
dangereux pour la société ou pour ses
collègues et donc ça sous-entend qu'il
est coupable avant même d'avoir été jugé
oui c'est un peu ça à dire que ce qui
est ce qui est fou dans la sphère
abattre on vient faire là on est
innocent comme dans toutes ces affaires
là ce qui est fou c'est le tout le monde
savait quand l affaire ppda sort on se
dit tout le monde savait là moi je peux
vous dire si je me suis dit tout le
monde serre dont je vais vous donner
l'image personnelle j'étais à tf1
pendant 17 ans avec ppda moi j'ai jamais
eu deux collègues femmes qui soit venu
me voir en me disant que patrie
prudemment s'était mal comporté et en
revanche y avait une réputation de
séducteur de dragueur de tout ce que
vous voulez mais jussie de passe
si mon témoignage il vaut ce qu'il vaut
je suis je suis peut-être une autre qui
ont vécu différemment mais moi c'est
comme ça si vous voulez dans présumé
innocent faudrait pas entendre que
innocent il faudrait aussi entendre
présumé d'accord et de la même façon
qu'on accorde évidemment les
institutions françaises à pas nous une
présomption d'innocence et que c'est
comme ça qu'est bâti notre système
judiciaire et c'est tant mieux et encore
une fois il s'agit pas d'envoyer à
badens prison avant qu'ils aient été
jugés il serait bon qu enfin on accorde
une présomption de crédibilité aux
victimes là haut quand elle pas oui
voilà madame on est justement de l'arnon
de ça c'est dommage alors attendez on
vous a beaucoup entendu tout à l'heure
donc je sais tout la force va terminer
la présomption de crédibilité c'est quoi
c'est simplement de se poser la question
quel est l'intérêt d'une femme à dire
qu'elle a été violée quand ça n'a pas
été le cas c'est quoi son intérêt de
mentir c'est l'argent non certainement
pas vous savez quand on porte plainte
pour viol il faut déposer de l'argent en
question ici la plainte sa mère abusive
elle est encaissé donc l'argent on n'est
pas la notoriété je pense qu'elle se
passerait d'une notoriété pareil donc la
vraie question à se poser c'est pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles le font mais
vous avez raison à l'argument majeur je
crois que c'est ce sont les cas de
russie ce sont les cas bayrou ce sont
les cadets ministres qui ont été écartés
alors je prends avec nos téléspectateurs
c'est l'objet d'une chronique juste
après donc on y reviendra tout à l'heure
ça redon de chardons de mener le de
mener le débat
ce que ce ce que vous venez de dire sur
le
la présomption de crédibilité c'est
exactement l'argument de laurence
rossignol la sénatrice socialiste de
l'oise vice-présidente du sénat c'était
dans une interview à libération il ya
plusieurs mois au mois de décembre il
faut ajouter à la présomption
d'innocence une présomption de
crédibilité des plaignantes qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette notion c'est
une absurdité mais pourquoi pour je vous
l'expliqué parce que la parole des
femmes elle a eu tellement de mal à
s'exprimer bien cela a été si mal reçus
dans les saucisses arrière dans une
gendarmerie pendant des décennies mais
bien peu longtemps dans les annales mois
mais ce n'est pas symétrique est ce que
ça veut dire la présomption d'innocence
c'est une réserve de du droit d'ailleurs
je vous ferai remarquer que dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme tout
tout homme est présumé innocent mais du
point de vivre la loi tout homme autant
d'êtres humains au sens anthropologique
d'accord mais tout au niveau de la loi
la loi guigou de demi de juin 2000
protège la présomption d'innocence dans
le cadre d'une procédure pénale ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que quand vous
êtes mis en cause dans une procédure
pénale vous êtes protégé votre processus
présomption d'innocence se protéger même
si elle est violée sans arrêt on l'a vu
dans la sphère ruggia d'ailleurs famille
collin a réussi à faire annuler
rétrospectivement et les soins
psychiatriques délirant qui ont été
imposées à christophe ruggia avant même
tout jugement toute expertise est la
garde à vue tout à fait aberrantes aussi
après coup ça a été déclaré illégal
c'est à dire on prétendait rendre la
justice en violant la loi pour rendre
pour faire plaisir à me toutefois ce
terme là mais c'est vrai et d'autre part
la présomption d'innocence alors ça veut
dire si vous n'êtes pas mis en cause par
une procédure pénale elle ne vous ne
pouvez pas vous défendre d2b médias ddb
réseaux sociaux etc c'est à dire vous
pouvez engagé aucune action sauf en
diffamation ou dénonciation calomnieuse
on sait ce que c'est et que c'est
compliqué maintenant ça veut dire c'est
juste une réserve du droit qui veut dire
que tant qu'à une personne n'a pas été
déclaré coupable par un tribunal
elle est réputée innocente ça veut pas
dire qu'elle est innocente c'est ça la
présomption maintenant la présomption de
crédibilité ou la présomption de
sincérité c'est pas symétrique c'est à
dire que à part qu'est le moment où le
slogan be tous ces victimes on vous
croit d'ailleurs déjà on dit victime
avant même qu'ils aient été des victimes
déclarées ça veut dire que à partir du
moment où on parle c'est l'accusation
vos projets en plus la scène irrité par
don rées d'hermine on peut être
parfaitement sincère et pour autant se
raconter une histoire en revisitant
quelque chose qu'on a vécu pour prendre
un exemple ailleurs que dans le cas des
accusations sexuelle dans un c'est une
chose dont vous dire moi qui supplie
kahn est gelée vue sans arrêt ce genre
de choses j'ai vu aussi des femmes
violées effectivement aux victimes
d'inceste ou des hommes quelqu'un qui
est par exemple un jaloux pathologique
croyez qu'il n'est pas sincère vous
croyez qu'il n'est pas convaincant qui
ne croit pas vraiment à ce qui dit on
attend cet argument j'essaye de j'essaie
d'équilibrer la parole qu'ils soient
vrais mélanie vogel je reste sur cette
notion de de présomption de crédibilité
des plaignantes est-ce que vous jugez
que c'est important justement au regard
de l'histoire de des plaintes qui n'ont
pas été entendus l'histoire mais aussi
au regard des faits c'est à dire que ce
qui se passe encore aujourd'hui et puis
jusque du pourcentage réel de ce que
sont les dénonciations calomnieuses
c'est quoi
pour cela il ya peu d'études qui ont été
faites sur le sujet surtout dans les
pays anglo saxons on est sur deux à 8 %
et 8 % on inclut les non lieux et les
classements sans suite et c'est donc en
gros aux statistiquement mons et qu'a
priori quand une femme dit qu'elle a été
victime de viol
95% des fois elle dit la vérité est
comme ça a été très bien dit a raison
parce que franchement pourquoi on irait
dire ça quand c'est pas vrai et donc la
maison non vraiment il ya beaucoup plus
de raison de ne pas le dire non donc oui
si mme jane dans votre démonstration je
vous redonne la parole c'est vous
l'impression que vous mettez en doute la
parole de ces minots une manière
générale doit être pas davantage je ne
mets pas les jeunes la met pas en doute
c'est à dire que là-bas quand il
respectait la parole du plaignant tu
quand elle va se plaindre oui c'est
absolument essentiel ça veut dire pas ça
veut pas dire va pas ouvrir la valve à
porter ça c'est un peu plus technique et
un peu moins porter plainte j'ai rêvé
quand elle va porter plainte déposé une
plainte bien sûr qu'il faut respecter sa
parole mais respectez ça ne veut pas
dire la croire à priori ça veut dire là
qu'on l'entende entièrement avec
délicatesse mais c'est la même chose
pour la personne qui le mis en cause le
mis en cause il peut mentir il peut dire
vrai aussi mais mélanie vosges m mais
c'est terminé oui donc bon effectivement
il faut croire les personnes qui dit ça
parce qu'à 95% des cas elles disent la
vérité est une chose que je voulais dire
aussi sur sur cette histoire de
la présomption d'innocence et la
condamnation etc c'est que on a quand
même un gros problème en france sur
notre définition pénale du viol 1 vous
savez que la france ne respecte pas ses
propres engagements internationaux la
france a signé et ratifié la convention
d'istanbul qui exige que le viol soit
défini par l'absence de consentement
d'accord en france dans le code pénal
malheureusement ce n'est pas défini
comme ça il faut pour des qualifiés
pénalement le viol consent capacité de
prouver qu'il ya eu contrainte menace
violence surprise est donc même si on
est capable de prouver qu'ils n'avaient
pas de consentement il n'y aura pas de
condamnation ce qui est un problème la
france est en violation du droit
international de ce point de vue là et
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas corriger ça
tant qu'on n'aura pas une justice qui
fonctionne normalement de toute façon
cette histoire d'attendre qu'il y ait
des condamnations même si et je veux
encore le dire il ne s'agit pas quand
être nommé ministre n'est pas un droit
d'accord ne pas être nommé ministre ce
n'est pas une sanction un an personne
ministre ici on n'a pas été sanctionné
d'accord c'est juste qu'on n'a pas été
choisie politique
on sait aussi mettre fin à la carrière
d'un homme politique avec une averse
situation calomnieuse enfin va pas
manger dit qu'il faisait des choses
et donc vous savez que après faut
choisir mais l'an passé où est le risque
comprend est ce qu'on prend le risque de
garder un violeur au gouvernement ou est
ce qu'on prend le risque statistiquement
il est très faible j'ai entendu de
règlement pour le coup moi j'aimerais
bien qu'on le site sur ces cinq
dernières années
tous ces innocents accusé à tort et dont
la carrière s'est retrouvé brisé et qui
se sont retrouvés en taule pour rien
petit aparté simplement par émission
vous parliez de luc besson tout à
l'heure la justice considère qu'il est
innocent donc ils rentrent dans cette
catégorie d'âge a su malgré les
arguments vous donner toutes les suites
que rien n'a été brisée pour lui qui
continue à travailler que et que abu non
non tout le monde tout va bien si on
regarde pareil ce qui se passe à
l'étranger vous avez le maire de coop de
copenhague il ya deux ans qui a été
accusé de harcèlement sexuel qui s'est
dit innocent mais qui a dit je me retire
la vie politique parce que ces
accusations la vont pourrir la vie
politique de la mairie même chose avec
le ministre de la défense britannique
michael phalen en 2017 pour les mêmes
raisons en disant je suis innocent mais
le temps la procédure en fait je pense
que ça risque de perturber légèrement
l'action du gouvernement donc je me
retire en france ça n'arrive jamais
d'accord on va faire le bilan laetitia
avec vous de ce mouvement me to
politique à vous considérer qu'il n'y a
pas eu de mitu politique non maintenant
j'ai bien compris qu'on avait tenté de
le lancer mais il me semble qu'il n'y a
pas eu de mitu politique comme il ya eu
amis tous par exemple à hollywood où il
ya des réalisateurs connus des
producteurs qui ont été écartés
définitivement du système en politique
non à part georges tron qui c'est vrai a
été inculpé et incarcéré à la prison de
la santé on a eu la sphère denis baupin
huit femmes qui l'ont accusé de violence
de violence ou de viols et finalement a
été classée sans suite pourquoi parce
qu'il y avait prescription on a eu
nicolas hulot mais c'était après son
départ sa démission du gouvernement et
cela fait quand même une dizaine
d'années que les femmes parlent ce n'est
pas là c'est pas les deux dernières
années ça fait une dizaine d'années à
l'assemblée nationale par exemple il ya
eu des pétitions il y a même une cellule
weil qui est chargée des cds violences
sexuelles dont seraient victimes les
femmes les députés les attachés
parlementaires mais les députés sont
couverts par leur immunité parlementaire
donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a vraiment
des limites à cette libération de la
parole bien sûr dans le sillage de
l'affairé dsk il est beaucoup de femmes
qui ont parlé en politique mais ça n'a
été sans aucune conséquence concrète et
puis la parole des femmes on sent
qu'elle est encore vraiment contraintes
empêcher pourquoi bas parce que quand on
est dans l'ombre on risque de perdre son
job et quand on est dans la lumière il y
à tous les obstacles qui se dressent
c'était c'est aurélie filippetti
l'ancien ministre de la culture qui en
parlent le mieux elle a fait à l'automne
elle a fait plusieurs plateaux de
télévision pour parler d'une affaire qui
remonte à 2010 ce qui concerne à jérôme
cahuzac quand ils étaient tous les deux
à l'assemblée nationale écoutez la quand
on est l'un et l'autre devenu ministre
moi j'avais alerté françois hollande
j'avais alerté jean marc ayrault j'avais
alerté un certain jean pierre moscovici
personne ne me croyait puisque jérôme
cahuzac raconté que nous avions eu une
histoire ensemble et que c'était moi qui
ne qui vivait très mal notre prétendue
séparation donc oui c'était salariale
allez c'est parti françois hollande vous
dis je ne vous crois pas mais lui seul
mais j'ai le souvenir une de vos
collègues journalistes qui avait écrit
dans un de ses livres il y a deux
versions de l'histoire et si maintenant
il y en a qu une version d'histoire il
suffit de regarder les chiffres par
exemple delà de la réserve parlementaire
de la commission des finances donc voyez
il ya des choses c'est tout simplement
inaudi parce que tu as sont les femmes
avaient toujours tort dans cette
histoire elle parle de la réserve
parlementaire parce que sa réserve avait
été vraiment baissé à la suite de son
refus après les avances de jérôme
cahuzac et le problème elle explique
très bien aurélie filippetti c'est que
personne ne l'a cru et qu'encore
aujourd'hui il y a un problème dans la
parole des femmes qui ne se sont pas
visiblement à la même hauteur que celle
des hommes en termes de crédibilité est
ce que vous diriez que le milieu
politique est plus sexiste que les
vôtres
non enfin il est très sexiste comme tous
les milieux où il ya beaucoup de pouvoir
beaucoup d'ego et beaucoup d'hommes donc
il n'y a pas que la politique mais c'est
vrai qu'il est pardon jeter via les
médias il ya aussi les médias voilà non
mais c'est pas le seul il l'est en
particulier
voilà mais je voulais juste revenir sur
nous on ne croit pas on n'a pas que oui
on a pas que la parole de ce qu'on voit
quand même et c'est ce qu'on verra
peut-être ça avec damien abad c'est
qu'en fait
souvent c'est vrai une femme qui parle
ça ne suffit pas
et puis quand il y en a 10 15 20 là ça
commence à
voilà là on se dit bon vin quand même
comme si une ça ne suffisait pas et je
suis moi je suis convaincu je ne sais
pas si ça va arriver mais je suis
convaincu qu'ils s'il ya des nouvelles
accusations et kanfen damien abad et
accusé non pas par deux personnes dont
une anonyme et par 15 lens dire ah ouais
non quand même 15 bornes à l aller dit
j'aurais lavigilante syli a d'autres des
nouveaux éléments jeu prendra des
mesures alors justement je voulais
promise voilà la chronique de jonathan
dupriez sur la gestion par emmanuel
macron de toutes ces affaires on a un
peu l'impression qu'il a rejoint soir
jonathan naviguer à vue avec avec les
ministres voilà j'ai accusé par cette
affaire oui accusé de viol un vous
l'avez dit par deux femmes pourquoi
damien abad n'at-il pas démissionné ça
c'est vraiment une question que beaucoup
de français se sont posés et apparemment
emmanuel macron lui aussi s'est posé la
question puisque ça a suscité un certain
embarras quand même au gouvernement sauf
que la justice ne sait pas donc saisi de
cette affaire emmanuel macron s'en est
remis à cela et donc son ministre des
solidarités ne tombent sous le coup
d'aucune procédure eh bien il peut
rester en poste comme ça malgré le tollé
suscité dans l'opinion alors ça c'est
pas sans rappeler un cas similaire en
2020 l'actuel ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin avait lui aussi conservé
le soutien du chef de l'état malgré des
accusations de viols et de violences
sexuelles emmanuel macron lui même avait
pris la défense de son ministre un jeu
le site à partir du moment où il est
accusé mais pas jugé il devient en
quelque sorte la victime d'un jugement
de rue ou de réseaux sociaux s'était ému
le président de la république dénonçant
une démocratie d'opinion et gérald
darmanin avait ensuite été blanchi par
la justice un insensé mais macro et
applique dans ces deux cas la
jurisprudence tant qu un ministre n'est
pas mise en examen il reste en poste oui
c'est ça sauf que certains cas non pas
du tout obéit à cette logique et je
prends cet exemple un sous le
quinquennat précédent en étant 2021 eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux et bien
il a été mis en examen pour prise
illégale d'intérêts par la cour de
justice de la république il aurait en
fait profiter des moyens de son
ministère pour régler des comptes avec
des magistrats anti corruption quant à
certaines anciennes affaires lorsqu'il
était avocat
même donc là encore du pont éric
dupond-moretti il a été soutenu par jean
castex et par emmanuel macron il est
donc resté en poste et devient même donc
d'être reconduit à la place vendôme et
pourtant emmanuel macron candidat en
2017 il avait été sans équivoque écouter
quand même sur votre conception des
choses si vous étiez mis en examen
est-ce que vous renonciez être candidat
mais il ya une façon que dans le
principe un ministre doit quitter le
gouvernement lorsqu'il est mise en
examen on a vu que ça n'a pas eu lieu
pour eric dupond moretti
pourtant ce d'autres ministres on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure ont été débarqués
pour moins que ça oui un château yquem
sur la table quelques homards de belle
réception à l'hôtel de lassay ça vous
dit peut-être quelque chose on est en
2019 et en pleine crise des gilets
jaunes vous le voyez à l'écran paraître
un article de mediapart qui tombe au
plus mauvais moment pour le ministre de
la transition écologique on apprend en
fait dans cet article que françois de
rugy bien ils menaient une sorte de vide
château lorsqu'il était président de
l'assemblée nationale une vie de château
bien sûr aux frais du contribuable
aucune enquête ne sera pourtant ouverte
à la suite de ces révélations mais le
ministre est devenu la risée des réseaux
sociaux et de l'opinion il est donc
contraint de démissionner donc au final
voilà après cinq ans de ces de ces
polémiques y en a eu il y en a 14 ans
des ministres qui ont été visés par des
affaires seuls 7 ont démissionné et on
comprends toujours pas bien la logique
qu'applique emmanuel macron à ses
ministres d'autant plus que là on voit
que certains ministres ceux qui sont
toujours sous le coup d'une enquête je
pense à olivier du soft et à sébastien
lecornu eh bien ils viennent d'être
promu au gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes
merci à jonathan pour pour tous ces
détails voilà pardon nous avoir
interrompu tout à l'heure mais ça
permettait de ne pas totalement vidé
cette rubrique de cela de sa substance
du lit à feuilles vous connaissez ça
évidemment très bien mais je vous
redonne la parole sur ce thème là parce
qu'il ya une forme est là on revient à
notre thématique de
du mythe ou politique et du bilan d'
emmanuel macron il ya eu une attente en
2010 est de votre part mais moi j'y ai
cru mais moi j'ai eu la naïveté de
croire quand emmanuel macron fait son
grand discours pour nous expliquer que
ça y est l'égalité femmes hommes et
surtout la lave à lui dix hommes femmes
et bref sur la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes c'est de la
grande cause du quinquennat et j'y ai
cru 1 48 heures assez rapidement je me
suis dit ça sent pas bon et quant au
moment de la mort de samuel pâtit
le tweet présidentielle c'est la
république est bonne fille elle ne se
laissera pas violer on se dit ok donc un
mini marie l'art est un bon prix
au pire c'est d'un cynisme hallucinant
de rappeler à toutes celles qui vont
lire ce tweet que si elles ont été
violées c'est qu'elles n'ont pas été
bonnes filles est donc là c'était
terminé je n'ai plus jamais cru au delà
de darmana au delà de tout ça évidemment
poussent toutes les questions que l'on
sait moi la seule question que je me
pose aujourd'hui est que je continue de
me poser en tant que femme en tant que
journaliste en tant que que tout ce que
vous voulez c'est pourquoi c'est si
compliqué de croire une femme quand elle
dit qu'elle a été violée pourquoi c'est
beaucoup plus facile de se dire qu'elle
ment pourquoi c'est plus facile que de
se dire que oui peut-être que cet homme
a violé qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se passe
en nous pour qu'on ne supporte pas
l'idée est que du coup on n'envisage
même pas l'impossibilité qu'elle dise
vrai qu'est-ce qu'on protège en nous de
quoi on a peur en fait qu'est ce qui se
passe pour que cinq ans après le début
de mitu on est toujours la même réaction
épidermique systématique helmand mais
non je veux dire pourquoi est-ce-que
pourquoi vous passez c'est un peu mieux
manica ce que vous dites croire ou dire
qu'elle ment ne pas croire un priori ça
veut dire enquêter dans un dans une
procédure pénale équitable écoutez aussi
le mis en cause c'est ça l'état de droit
excusez moi pour tout justifier en
france il ya deux choses que je voudrais
quand même dire vous pariez de passer de
l'une à 15 vous aimeriez bien qu'ils en
aient 20 finalement contre damien bac
mais si je veux dire vous aimeriez bien
parce que ça donnerait quant à l'idée
que voilà moi aussi moi aussi moi aussi
c'est facile de dire moi aussi noyé
facile le passé pas si ça n'avait pas le
droit je n'avais absolument pas le droit
de dire c'est facile moi aussi j'ai été
violée ça c'est interdit mais le jeune
20 ans et non non non non vous mélangez
tout gelé l'an ça n'est pas facile on ne
part non c'est tout à fait ce n'est pas
la même chose de signer une tribune 343
ses fonctions peu près aussi j'ai été
violée est facile maintenant c'est un
clic et anonymement moi aussi oui c'est
facile sans qu'il s'agisse à il en a
plein qui sont pas de notre fait mais
oui mais ensuite vous voyez on mélange
le viol 1-1 propos déplacés un regard
qu'on a considéré comme un viol et donc
voilà c'est ça votre continuum des
violences sexistes et sexuelles
le continueraient mais c'est une erreur
de penser profonde et c'est une erreur
psychologique profonde aussi je peux
vous dire que mes patientes qui ont été
violées j'en ai eu qui ont été violées
qui entendent que sandra muller est
gravement traumatisé à cause d'une
phrase graveleuses prononcé que cinq ans
auparavant
et bien je peux vous dire qu'elle
considère ça comme une insulte à lomé
mal mais pardon formulaire c'est la
journaliste luc a lancé en france
balance tant que maman ballon et je
termine l'autre chose que je voulais
dire c'est votre question de principe de
précaution mais c'est quand même quelque
l humiliation pour les femmes de penser
qu'elles doivent être protégés comme si
elle était sous tutelle principe de
précaution hammouche alemany a fait dans
l'express hier un excellente tribune la
suivre sur moi j'ai lu les témoignages
de chloé et margot quand vous lisez ça
vous vous dites mais quand même c'est
pas sérieux ce qu'elle la façon dont
s'est dit ça il y en a une qui dit
candidement à libération à mai ce qui
est formidable c'est qu'on a
l'impression d'avoir une armée numérique
qui croît les femmes mais c'est
pathétique excusez moi c'est pathétique
ces milieux politiques analyse oui moi
psychanalyste je me permets et je sais
de quoi je parle vous plaît mais c'est
hermine une phrase ou c'est pas possible
ça c'est vous qui me laissait pas
terminé alors
pas les hymnes et la parole donc vous
psychanalyste vous permettez de remettre
en question un travail d' enquête d'un
an et demi fait par une journaliste oui
dans tout jeu le travail on est par
exemple les enquêtes de marine turchi un
jeu c'est très doux airs de malte
fonctionne turquie moi il y en a qui
disent turchi alors on va on va essayer
de faire en sorte qu'au final c'est
s'exprimer giuly affreuse g 10e juste
avant le repos mais l'entente est parce
que je trouve que je trouve que pour une
psychanalyste qui entend des femmes oui
ils ont des familles et des hommes aussi
belges en fait je n'ai pas terminé parce
que les laisser à déterminer s'il vous
plaît allez j ai envers les femmes merci
donc c'est vous qui me donnait la parole
je vous remercie à cause des coûts bref
je suis très surprise de voir komsic
analystes qui entend des femmes
sur son divan ou en fait peu importe
quand on connaît les statistiques
effectivement vous en avez entendu plus
d'une
que vous puissiez imaginer qu'on se
fasse très plaisir à dire j'ai été
violée me fait dire mais avec quel
moment vous ai jamais gagnante de ce que
s'il vous plaît laissez moi laissez moi
aller au bout de ma phrase s'il vous
fait dire ce que je n'ai pas dit alors
je vous mets permet d'afficher ainsi
déjà bon enfant façon le débat est
quasiment terminé simplement j'ai été
victime de viol d'accord je n'ai jamais
considéré que ce qu'avait fait sandra
muller était une insulte à ce que
j'avais vécu les victimes de viol sont
pas décérébrés pour autant je la
remercie d'avoir lancé le mouvement qui
a donné ce que ça donne au journal voilà
bien sûr la parole a été suffisamment je
l'espère en tout cas partagé merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vais rappeler les titres de vos livres
je suis une sur deux giulia foïs et
publié aux éditions flammarion
et sabine cauris le mirage mitu aux
éditions le cherche-midi merci encore
une fois d'avoir participé à ce débat